Speaker 1: Guys, I have to tell you I am taking
pleasure in someone else's misfortune. You know
that the German term schadenfreude means pleasure
derived by some other person's misfortune.
And I admit I am taking pleasure in the fact that
Donald Trump's Truth social app is collapsing
and has seen a 93 percent drop in signups since
the week that they launched. I don't take pleasure
in the illness and death of others, even when
those people are disgusting when Rush Limbaugh
had lung cancer and died. I said, Listen,
there are people who love this guy. And while
the globe may be better off with him not doing his
show, I don't take pleasure in illness or death.
I don't take pleasure in the job losses of hard
working people or the break ups of relationships
that are meaningful to others. But when you put up
an obvious Twitter clone and you claim that you're
doing it because they're censoring conservatives
on social media and blah blah blah, and then it
fails miserably. I love it. I absolutely love
it. This is a great report from The Wrap.
The would be Twitter killer has drawn only 1.2
million installations, according to Sensor Tower.
Former President Donald Trump's Truth social
app is seeing a 93 percent drop in signups
and similarly steep decline in traffic after a
rocky rollout last month, fraught with technical
issues and an extensive waiting list for new
sign ups to actually use the service. After going
live on President's Day, the Twitter look site
installs declined by more than 800000 since its
launch week. Installs on the Apple App Store this
month have fallen to about 60000 per week based
on early estimates. Now if you're like just some
amateur app builder and you're not putting out
something viral or whatever 60000 app installs
a week really isn't bad. We have the former
president of the United States here channeling
all of the platforms, an ability that he has,
as well as his children doing it, as well
as all sorts of his former staffers saying
This is going to be God's gift to social media.
It's going to dominate. And then you open signups
and the website can't handle the traffic.
Initially, people are put on a waiting list,
then everybody just forgets about it and doesn't
care. And now nobody's even signing up. And both
Don Jr. and Eric Trump over the last 24 hours have
tried to promote the app, try to resuscitate it,
bring it back to life by posting how they are
now on it. Eric Trump tweeted yesterday, I'm
live. Come join the party on Untruth Social. It's
also kind of funny that it took weeks for Eric
Trump to even get his account activated. So I love
this. Tell me I'm a bad person for loving this.
I'm ready for it. But this is a type of misfortune
that I absolutely take pleasure and just another
embarrassing, humiliating failure for the
former president. And we'll have screenshots
from the app and more information about this.
I call it a glorious failure I really do
on our Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show.